all right drafting the best players in
the afc west trivia question goes to
chris
for the first pick in the draft of the
best players in the afc west the afc
west has a combined 17 super bowl
appearances in its history which is the
second most of any divisions in the nfl
actually it's third because there are
two that are tied for first place
name the two divisions that are tied for
first with 21 super bowl appearances
each
i have to name them both huh okay name
them bob come on you there's only eight
divisions and it's going to be one in
each conference and we've already
eliminated i'm gonna go with this afc
the afc east is one of them
right am i right about that one just
tell me am i right af okay and then the
second one i'm gonna say is the nfc's
you are correct
you get patrick mahomes we should have
exempted patrick mahomes from this this
should be patrick mahomes memorial draft
he should not be part of this do you
want to just do that do you just want to
take him off the board and make no i
want everybody on social media to see my
picks and go oh sims and sticks are so
much better as an idiot okay so no
you're right you probably should have
done that but yes i mean come on let's
let's wax poetically about the guy that
we know is the best player in football
right now i mean yeah patrick mahomes is
my first pick and this guy has got a
chance to go down as the greatest of all
time and you know i still don't know if
we all compromi comprehend what the hell
we just saw in that last super bowl one
of the greatest the
maybe the best defense this year i would
say it was the best defense them are the
patriots one of the best pass defenses
we've seen in the history of the nfl up
20 to 10 with a great pass rush and
third and 15
and the game just the pendulum momentum
everything swung on one play two two jet
wasp because of patrick mahomes and to
me yes i mean this is a no-brainer we
picked the best players in the nfl he'd
be the number one pick let alone the afc
west
yeah you're absolutely right i mean
we've seen some divisions that were
chock full of great players but none are
greater than patrick mahomes even though
he was not the league mvp last year
number one lamar jackson's performance
had a lot to do with it but also that
knee injury that knocked him out for a
couple of weeks and also kept him from
really being himself again until
mid to late december i remember talking
to him chris after that game against
denver at home when they played in the
snow and that was really the moment
where we're like you know what
he's still patrick mahomes and i
remember asking him do you kind of like
the fact that
that the league and the media and the
fans really aren't focused on the chiefs
as a serious super bowl threat and he
said i like that very much and look at
what the end result was all right
um
it really gets no easier at this point
but here's where i'm going to go i'm
going to stay on the same team i'm going
to go with the second best player on the
chiefs you know who it is do you know do
you know do you know
chris jones chris jones i got i have to
i have to the and look he's not gonna
have 20 sacks but he can come close as a
defensive lineman you're going to wreak
havoc you're going to lead the league or
come close to it in your favorite
statistical category that is not yet
officially recognized the f up the play
stat chris jones
he effed up the super bowl for the 49ers
when the 49ers had the lead they're
trying to kill the clock and george
kittle's wide open because he was being
covered by terrell suggs what happened
chris jones put that big paw up in the
air and knocked the ball out of the sky
and then the next play on third down
when kittle was open again over the
middle garoppolo didn't even look there
because he was afraid chris jones was
going to do it again he's dominant
against the run he's dominant against
the pass he is a guy you have to always
account for and uh
yeah give me chris jones without
question gee we're figuring out why the
chiefs won the super bowl it's not just
mahomes the defense stepped up this year
remember last year we said if the chiefs
just get a little bit better on defense
they'll win the super bowl and they
didn't just get a little bit better they
got a lot better and chris jones is a
big reason why no doubt about it i mean
he you could put him in the conversation
from one of the best defensive players
in football and you're right mike i mean
the plays he made in the super bowl were
huge you know him getting his big hand
up there and batting down two passes
late in the fourth quarter where guys
were wide open let's not forget i
believe he was the guy that got the
pressure the the force garoppolo to
throw the interception in the first half
so
you know
you know you sit here and you look at it
and you go huh i wonder why the chiefs
have won the afc west the last few years
because really
my next pick i'm staying with the kansas
city chiefs i'm not going off their team
because tyree kill is going to be my
next pick i mean tyree kill is still in
the he's the number one weapon in
football i mean that's what he is he's a
great receiver he's a game changer he
changes how defense play him he allows
that offense of kansas city to draw
plays and do things that you know nobody
else in football could do yes one
because mahomes has the talent to launch
the ball 70 yards off his back foot as
he's falling down but then tyree kill
yeah it's not two rockets up its butt
it's three rockets up his butt he's you
know arguably the most explosive player
we've ever seen in the history of the
nfl i mean really he's up there to me
with dion sanders bo jackson
uh daryl green you know those guys right
there i go i don't know who the fastest
is but they're in the conversation for
the fastest people in the history of the
sport for me and yeah tyree kill i'm
taking them
and it's not just the top end speed it's
the way he explodes off the line of
scrimmage the way he can stop stop and
start right the things he does the fear
he strikes in the heart of a defense it
really is incredible what tyree kill has
accomplished and really not that long in
the nfl but when you've got that kind of
god-given ability you make an impact
right away like he did when he was
drafted by the chief several years ago
all right it's time to go with
uh
we've given half the draft to the chiefs
there are other teams there's one other
super bowl mvp from that division who we
have yet to give the due credit uh that
he deserves and that's von miller even
though von miller didn't have a great
season last year in vic fangio's first
year as head coach of the broncos miller
is still one of the permanent pass
rushers in the nfl he's had over 100
sacks in his career super bowl 50 mvp a
guy you have to game plan for a guy who
is very dangerous off the edge a guy who
i think is going to have a renaissance
type of a year in 2020 now that the
broncos have stabilized their offense
and vic fangio a little more comfortable
with that defense than maybe he was
right out of the gate so von miller
still one of the best players in the nfl
even though last year not indicative of
the kind of performances we've seen from
him since he entered the league back in
2011.
yeah well he's still a game changer to
what you're saying you're right i mean
you always and this is all around great
football player i mean he plays great
against the run let's not forget they
didn't have bradley chubb last year
right that didn't help things because it
just allows the focus to be on him that
much more there was really nobody on the
other side of the edge of that defense
to be scared about and you know von
miller i've heard him say he wants to
get back to being a little bigger and
stronger and i i like that he said that
you know that's one aspect of his game i
think you know he compromised a little
power to get back speed a few years ago
and i think he needs that power back but
man von miller without a doubt i mean
still one of the best players in
football first ballot hall of famer in
my opinion and a super bowl mvp yeah the
broncos won that super bowl because von
miller was a beast all right
i'm gonna go with a pass rusher i'm
gonna go with joey bosa from from the
los angeles chargers i think that's the
next guy on my list i mean i to me it
was between him and bond miller for the
two best you know defenders in the
division certainly pass rushers but both
the same way what you said about von
miller mike i mean he's he's a game plan
game plan designer
uh you know he makes you change it and
be aware he's going to keep offensive
coordinators up at night bose is
phenomenal against the runner in the
pass and you know really one of the
elite pass rushers and all the football
not so sure he's the best pass rusher in
his own family but he's one of the best
in all of football and that just speaks
to him but he can do it all he's just a
great athlete plays the run can turn
around the edge and get after the
quarterback i mean boss is a beast he's
uh he's my third pick
uh and you know
i i'm i'm trying to come up with a
raider
i know would jump over any of the guys
that are left for me i've got three or
four left
and maybe josh jacobs you could make the
argument i can't i derwin jd the charger
safety who is on the brink of greatness
if he stays healthy he is going to
become one of the best defensive backs
in all of football so i got to go derwin
james so the chargers squeeze into the
broncos have one the chiefs have three
and sorry raiders you have none but uh
look at the roster who is really there
that would scream out the kind of talent
that would compete with the guys that
we've listed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports